[Music]
right now as Senate lawmakers grill the
AG nominee William ball were learning
more about the deep state and the abuses
he'll be confronting when confirmed for
example according to reporting from our
own catherine herridge former top FBI
lawyer James Baker this is under Comey
is the subject now of a criminal
investigation into illegal leaks to the
media and there's also growing evidence
of the deep anti-trump bias among senior
FBI officials with Devon Nunez from the
house Intel committee revealing that the
bureau's leaders quote had no real
evidence against the Trump team but
launched an investigation
anyway following the Comey firing
joining us now with reaction is the
congressman himself congressman Devin
Nunez congressman when I hear that what
I'm hearing is that is a revenge
investigation but it already gone on for
nine months the remedial in the after
the they exonerated Hillary with no
investigation they launched the
so-called Trump Russia collusion
investigation nine months into it homies
fired but we learned from Peter struck
Lisa Paige McCain himself and call me
that they had nothing at that point why
would they sit in a room and basically
say well maybe the president conspired
with Putin of fire James Comey so Sean
let's think about it a different way so
we have these supposed Russia Hawks
sitting over at the counterintelligence
division at the FBI and DOJ where were
they in 2012 when when Barack Obama got
caught on a hot mic telling the Russian
leader at the time he needed he needed
more time to wait till after the
election it looks like that was trying
to work with the Russians where were
they investigating when the Ukrainians
were begging the United States for
weapons the Congress was was trying to
give weapons to the Ukrainians after the
Russians had invaded an annex Crimea
nobody went to investigate the Obama
White House or President Obama so you
have no evidence in this case you have
no records no phone calls absolutely
nothing of any sort and yet you
supposedly reportedly are investigating
the president and furthermore supposedly
this scope memo that outlines whatever
mole are supposed to be
looking at if the New York Times story
is to be believed from last Friday night
a Friday night news dumb if that's to be
believed then that means that somebody
leaked pieces of that scope memo to the
New York Times and we still have yet to
see it here in the Congress well John
Ober supposed to be investigating that
way he's been working a long time we
could use an update I don't know if
you've seen this piece in The Epoch
Times the headline is McCabe's try FBI
try to reengage Christopher Steele after
Comey was fired and they have a
transcript supposedly by Bruce or
showing the FBI went back to steal
between commis firing and Muller's
appointment now we also know that there
was communication Bruce or was the
conduit if you will for Christopher
steel and he was trying to get his
information remember he's been
discredited the dossier has been
discredited he was fired for lying and
leaking from the FBI but yet he's still
in contact with all these top officials
and trying to feed information to Muller
which we got in the exchanges with Bruce
or so remember how we got here so we set
up a task force we gave a list to at the
at the end of the last Congress or
actually last summer a task force was
created to do conduct a bunch of
interviews what supposedly now is
leaking out are pieces of these
interviews that chairman Gowdy and
chairman Goodlatte had to ask to for the
FBI and DOJ to release them they sat on
them now I think what's happening is
people are selectively leaking pieces of
this so I read the story in the epic
times I have not read all the
transcripts so I don't know if that is
true or not but obviously it's very
alarming if it's true that in that time
period that they were already trying to
go back to steal and get him to come
back after they knew he was terminated
for lying and misleading the FBI very
very concerning and I think we need to
know more about this which is why these
transcripts from all these interviews
need to be released we got to hope that
the new Attorney General gets into this
deep I agree with you all right
congressman unas thank you very much all
right